un acheteur condamné pour exhibition
sexuelle dans une émission qui cartonne
puisque c'était la semaine dernière tony
mazzarri de la série les mystères de
l'amour sur tmc savait plus d'un million
à chaque fois condamné à deux mois de
prison avec sursis pour exhibition
sexuelle je voulais dis donc on s'est
posé aussi la question aussi parce que l
affaire quesada dont tout le monde parle
les stars ont-elles les moyens plutôt
les peler pardon les directions et les
productions ont-elles les moyens
d'identifier justement leur candidat on
va répondre à toutes ces questions parce
qu'on a travaillé
regardez et le scandale de la semaine
dernière tony mazzarri qui jouit
gaussant de chasse dans la série glee
stères de l'amour diffusée chaque
dimanche sur tmc est condamné à deux
mois de prison avec sursis pour
exhibition sexuelle devant des mineurs
un comportement qui n'a pas mis
longtemps à être sanctionnée par la
chaîne
le groupe tf1 annonce en début de
semaine que l'acteur était débarqué il
faut dire que deux semaines seulement
après l'arrestation de christian quesada
la sphère fait un peu désordre pour ceux
qui ne seraient pas encore au courant le
plus célèbre des candidats de jeu
télévisé avec 192 participation aux 12
coups de midi et 800000 euros de gains
le plus gros jamais gagné
a été incarcéré pour détention d'imagés
pédopornographiques
une affaire d'autant plus choquant que
le champion avait été déjà condamné à
deux reprises pour des affaires
similaires
face à ces différents scandales une
question se pose
les chaînes font elles vraiment ce qu'il
faut pour éviter de telles dérives pour
gilles verdez la réponse est très claire
c'est non
savoir que dans les émissions de tf1 on
ne demande pas des extraits de casier
judiciaire et il n'y a pas qu'en france
que les chaînes de télévision manque
sérieusement de vigilance tout le monde
se souvient de la chute de kevin speccy
pourtant super star de la série house of
cards du mal des postes dark chip est
accusé d'agression sexuelle sur mineur
plusieurs années après les faits et
cette semaine c'est au tour d' allison
mack la star de la série smallville
d'être accusé de trafic sexuel au sein
d'une secte et risque 40 ans de prison
accusé de laxisme la télévision
peut-elle vraiment tout savoir
voilà dans le cas donc de tenir il a été
condamné il fait appel mais donc là n'y
a pas de présomption d'innocence dans le
cas de quesada pour le moment il a avoué
mais il ya encore une présomption
d'innocence donc on va mettre des
conditionnels dans tout ça parce qu'on
est quand même en france si on respecte
les gens mais ma première question juste
avant c'est est-ce que vous parfois
justement vous pouvez pas le faire parce
que vous n'en avez pas les preuves dans
les magazines people l'udc ou myriam
vous entendez des rumeurs ça vous arrive
peut-être sur un quesada sur un tony ou
sur des gens comme ça ou sur des gens
connus vous entendez ces choses là mais
vous ne pouvez pas les sortir et ben oui
clairement ça nous arrive même assez
fréquemment d'avoir ce genre de choses
après tant qu'on n'a pas le casier
judiciaire ont fait rien mais par
exemple pour un quesada vous le saviez
alors pour qu'ils s'adaptent non non non
non tony da dont on parle non plus non
plus très bien mais sur des people mais
les victoires qu'on n'a pas de casier
judiciaire pour des gens comme vous se
procure un casier judiciaire c'est
l'enfance de l'art enfin benjamin
castaldi s'en est procuré il ya deux
semaines enfin pour vous il dressa
surtout qu'il faut qu'il y ait plainte
pour qu'on puisse en parler ça c'est dur
si la conne elle vient nous dire oui il
m'a fait ceci cela il faut créer une
plainte évoque une procédure en cours
sinon on dénonce comme ça ça va pas
alors pour que les gens comprennent bien
et surtout sébastien qui connaît bien le
dossier et catherine juste deux trois
petites questions pour que ce soit clair
est-ce que déjà donc c'est la question
les productions elle même donc soit la
production des douze coups de midi ou
téléréalité n'importe quoi une démone a
les moyens de se procurer un casier
judiciaire pour être sur ce qu on suivra
notamment de greg le millionnaire à
l'époque on avait découvert une fois à
tf1 qu'il avait un casier est ce
qu'elles ont les moyens de se procurer
le casier des candidats bah si la
production décide de faire une enquête
de moralité sur tous les candidats oui
moi je les fais pour une grosse émission
de télé réalité pendant plusieurs
saisons
donc j'avais une cinquantaine de
candidats checker il faut savoir que si
on n'a que le feuillet numéro 3 on voit
pas grand chose il faut savoir qu'à
casse du siècle aura feuillets ya trois
feuillets l'a donc pour vraiment se
donner une bonne idée il faut avoir les
trois fait hier vous avez que le dernier
vous voyez les peines supérieures à 2
ans de prison ferme donc la lecture
autorisée en avoir un des trois en
demandant vous pouvez avoir le troisième
qui sert en gros pas grand chose les
deux premiers vous n'y ait pas d'excès
donc il faut il faut se débrouiller
d'une manière ou d'une autre pour avoir
l'article r que même si
la production bande dans la sphère
quesada avait demandé le feuillet dans
lequel il avait été condamné pour
pédophilie elle n'aurait pas eu non il
faut passer par d'accord et détective ou
des gens comme moi qui a trouvé un moyen
de faire les yeux d une bêtise n'a pas
été condamnée donc comme ça autant pour
moi non mais même s'il a été arrêté vers
détention d'imagés pédopornographiques
mais même s'il a été arrêté voilà encore
des policiers peuvent le savoir même
s'il a été relâché mes jambes sont
encore deux trois questions notamment
aussi aux avec catherine aussi est ce
que par exemple un magistrat donc qui a
condamné la personne qui l'a vu dans un
tribunal qui regardent la télévision et
qui voient ce candidat qui a été
condamné est ce qu'elle peut appeler la
production ce magistrat ou est ce qu'on
peut appeler la production et dire ben
pardon mais la personne que vous voudrez
que vous mettez tous les jours à midi a
été condamné pour images
pédopornographiques
cette trêve question m'intéresse et
cette réponse m'intéresse la première
question qu'on s'était demandé c est ce
que les productions ont accès au jeu est
arrivé au judiciaire et donc sébastien
nous disait c'est en trois feuillets ils
ont accès à qu'un feuillet et les deux
où il ya vraiment vraiment les
cotisations n'ont pas et tout à l'heure
on parlait du coup à la pub dont on peut
dire plus de choses tu me faisais de
l'émission pour laquelle tu as travaillé
c'était certainement de l'intensité à
quel nom ah oui tu étais mon fils et il
y avait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup et en
fait les gens mentent énormément il ya
des gens qui en fait était marié l'heure
qu'il est célibataire ya des gens qui
avaient des enfants alors qu'ils
devaient pas comme les gens veulent
faire de la région y avait des pornos
s'était déjà fait du porno et gens qui
avaient des casiers donc faut vraiment
vraiment travailler à travailler les
diamants c'est pour ça que la prod
essayer d'aller en amont et s'était dit
bon bah pourquoi pas avec avec des
paradigmes des agences de presse parce
que son humeur générale qui sortent les
infos donc ils peuvent nous aider à
faire ses devoirs en amont et lascaux
vos jeux vos de quoi vous dire
maintenant et on cite pas non c'est
hallucinant vous allez voir comment ça
marche
vous m'avez dit sébastien parfois tu toi
je te vois moi vous voyez vous m'avez
dit pendant la pub que il arrive parfois
que vous ayez les titres des infos mais
pas de preuve et c'est quoi la suite
alors c'est à dire qu'on peut avoir des
infos très précise des plaintes sont
déposées les plaintes restent bloqués et
dans ces cas-là il ya ce qu'on appelle
des fuites et des fuites qui arrive
souvent et ça vient directement des
juges essaye de faire fuiter à la presse
pour débloquer la situation parce qu'une
fois que c'est médiatisé il
ils ont les reins sinon c'est
hallucinant il faut de l'argent pour
tous a aussi un et c'est hallucinant
donc vous vous savez plein de choses
tout à l'heure vous m'avez dit alors et
encore une fois je respect à sa famille
et tout ça et tout ça et voilà il a mais
à l'époque de delarue m'aviez dit
j'avais eu des infos sur lui beaucoup
beaucoup rsa ne va pas tout sur lui mais
effectivement temps en temps il ya des
infos qui sortent mais qui mis bout à
bout ces derniers jours ils savent être
intéressant sur il y avait eu ce qu'on
appelle la jurisprudence greg le
millionnaire pour ceux qui soutiennent
dans cette émission
ça commence sur tf1 c'était un énorme
carton plusieurs millions et aux
frontières et à etienne mougeotte
l'ancien président de tf1 bat découvre
que son millionnaire non seulement n'est
pas millionnaire mais un casier
judiciaire cesa et ça crée une
jurisprudence depuis les chaînes on
passe des contrats avec les maisons de
production qui contractuellement ont le
devoir de fournir pour la télé réalité
les candidats clean entre guillemets ce
qui fait que la chaîne c'est un problème
un problème peut se retourner contre la
maison de production pour les jeux c'est
complètement le bordel il ya tellement
casting tellement de candidats qui sont
incapables de nous il ya trois mois je
vous dire aussi quelque chose
d'intéressant que je connais bien parce
que très compliqué et je suis très
jamais de nom bah c'est que toutes les
jeunes filles ou jeunes garçons qui se
présente et qui rêve de tout ça bat
souvent malheureusement sont pas ceux
qu'on fait 16 ans d'études à
polytechnique mais qui rêve un petit peu
de télé et dans le lot bah on a des
escortes
on est des outils qui font certaines
choses on a c'est compliqué de tout
savoir mais cette table quand elle a été
castée pour l'émission quelli berda
n'est pas là la semaine prochaine
ce que je trouve aussi dur c'est que ok
quand on est dans une histoire de
pédophilie etc
je suis d'accord ça il faut bannir c'est
difficile de le savoir mais si on le
sait faut tout de suite stoppé c'est
normal oui maintenant on peut pas si il
dira des gens effectivement qui ont eu
un passé qui ont eu des problèmes c'est
dur aussi de dire ok donc parce que tu
as fait des erreurs tu n'as plus le
droit de vie qui n'a plus droit
travailler tu n'as plus drôle mais c'est
pour ça que c'est ce qu'ils aient une
partie du casier judiciaire on accepte
donc donc donc c'est dur quand même pas
mal à ce que vous dites c'est j'entends
même façon aujourd'hui vous savez que
tout sorte et paca mais à 30 ans josé
que les réseaux sociaux de façon tout
finit par se savoir